[Musique]
bonjour à tous Aujourd'hui c'est un lieu
hors des sentiers battus que nous allons
découvrir ensemble ici à Paris derrière
ces murs le Mobilier national conserve
quelques-uns de nos plus précieux
trésors des meubles des tapisseries des
pendules des objets d'art tous plus
étonnants et magnifiques les uns que les
autres et qui ont accompagné le destin
de nos rois de nos reines de nos
empereurs ou de nos présidents des
objets témoins de notre histoire
allez suivez-moi nous allons découvrir
ensemble le Mobilier national
[Musique]
les collections du Mobilier national
c'est un trésor de 100.000 biens
culturels qui ont été créés par des
artisans d'art ou des artistes les
meilleurs du moment pour les rois de
France les empereurs la République
[Musique]
c'est absolument magnifique
c'est des savoir-faire rare qui sont
perpétués on est un peu au cœur de
l'exception culturelle à la française
là vous rentrez en fait dans la réserve
la plus précieuse et toujours fermée à
clé et qui est en fait un peu le saint
des saints pour le textile
[Musique]
à partir du XVIème siècle apparaissent
les tapissiers valets de chambre du roi
il transporte les meubles dans des
coffres des chariots etc ils accrochent
ils entretiennent la cour s'installe et
lorsque la cour part ils sont chargés de
retirer tous les meubles de de les
mettre dans des chariots et de partir
ensuite vers le château suivant
[Musique]
on s'est rendu compte
par rapport aux règnes de François 1er
de Henri IV et de Louis XII qu'il
restait très peu de mobilier de ces rois
et la volonté Louis XIV comme il
désirait porter le mobilier Royal un
haut niveau de de richesse et de
somptuosité était donc de protéger tout
le mobilier aussi bien des tofs que des
bénisteries
[Musique]
ils étaient inscrits dans le journal du
Garde-Meuble qui est un document très
précieux sur des tapis civils de ce
mobilier ont donné à ce moment-là un
numéro aux meuble on indiquait le jour
d'enregistrement et une description
rapide du meuble ainsi que l'artisan qui
l'a livré
[Musique]
ses inventaires sont rédigés de la même
façon c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une
succession donc de chapitre qui aborde
les objets par matière vous avez par
exemple ici les les pierres riz ensuite
la vaisselle vous avez ensuite les
tapisseries ce qu'on appelle les grands
meubles c'est à dire les meubles de
textile les meubles d'ébénisterie
c'est-à-dire les cabinets piétables etc
[Musique]
vous avez dans la marge des inscriptions
qui permettent de voir le devenir de
certains objets quand ils ont disparu
par exemple ici on a déchargé le présent
en entier ayant été délivrés par ordre
de son altesse royale pour
l'établissement de l'hôpital royal de
Versailles donc voilà on retrouve un peu
un exemple d'un objet donné par le roi
un hôpital
[Musique]
ce qui subsiste à l'heure actuelle qui a
pu être identifié par rapport à donc à
ce qui est décrit dans ces volumes et
dérisoires
[Musique]
outre le rôle de prestige les
tapisseries joués en rôle pratique tout
d'abord de camoufler des murs nus en
pierre mais également de protéger du
froid de protéger de l'humidité et des
courants d'air généralement les
tapisseries étaient suspendus sur tout
le mur et s'il y avait une porte elle
passait devant la porte donc pour sortir
de la pièce il fallait soulever la
tapisserie et cela présentait l'avantage
d'éviter des vents coulis ce genre de
choses
[Musique]
cette épicerie est particulièrement
remarquable elle met le fil d'or fil de
soie file de laine et on peut apprécier
également la grande vivacité des
couleurs la variété des coloris on voit
des violets des vers des bleus des
rouges éclatants
[Musique]
il s'agissait d'oeuvre que l'on mettait
parfois plusieurs années à tisser et
pour lesquels un nombre très important
d'artisans devaient être sollicités il y
avait des liciers spécialisés notamment
dans les visages d'autres dans le
traitement des éléments décoratifs des
fleurs des animaux des objets il
s'agissait d'oeuvres extrêmement
luxueuses générant des coûts de
production très élevés
[Musique]
la manufacture des Gobelins était
reprend une idée de Henri IV qui déjà
dans les galeries du Louvre avait réuni
quelques ateliers de de tapissier Louis
XIV a développé cette idée en
l'élargissant au mobilier mobilier
d'argent mobilier d'ébénisterie
[Musique]
donc on voit ici le roi accompagné de
Colbert en train d'admirer la grande
variété des productions qui étaient
exécutées par les ateliers des Gobelins
donc on peut voir de superbes tables des
pièces d'orfèvrerie exceptionnelles
gigantesques des étoffes précieuses des
tapis des tapisseries
[Musique]
le but était impressionné par la
richesse du mobilier d'impressionner par
la richesse de la cour pour montrer que
malgré la guerre malgré les dépenses le
royaume reste puissant et donc
redoutable
[Musique]
ce sont des bijoux à l'échelle d'un
espace qui aurait éclaboussé le monde il
faut bien le dire c'est ça qui a fait la
gloire de Louis XIV
[Musique]
l'objectif c'était d'humilier le doge et
en même temps de montrer la puissance et
la magnificence du roi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mot gobelin était extrêmement connu
il signifie tapisserie aussi bien en
langue anglaise allemande kodanmark en
Suède qu'en Norvège en disait qu'on veut
acheter un gobelin tout le monde savait
ce que l'on voulait acheter et en
général c'était une tenture comprenant
plusieurs tapisseries
[Musique]
vous avez deux nappes de chaînes ces
deux nappes de chêne elles sont séparées
par des bâtons de verre qui courent tout
du long et qui sépare les donuts la
nappe avant est libre et la nappe
arrière vous pouvez voir que
à chaque fil de la nappe arrière est
relié une petite cordelette de coton
et ces petites cordelettes de coton on
les appelle les lisses et le mot lissier
qui nous désigne vient de là
je fais un aller simple entre les deux
nappes avec cet outil qui s'appelle la
broche donc là je fais mon allée normale
entre les deux nappes je tasse avec la
pointe de la broche
et après il faut que je fasse mon retour
donc si je fais un retour
classique ça va pas parce que je défais
ce que j'ai déjà tissé
donc je vais aller chercher les lisses
et en tirant sur les lisses
la nappe arrière passe à l'avant et les
deux nappes se croisent là je passe ma
broche
et je tasse
ce geste qu'on pratique aujourd'hui
c'est exactement le même qu'on
pratiquait depuis trois siècles et le
principe de la chaîne des lys et du
métier antisé à tisser en lui-même c'est
le même que à la création des Gobelins
[Musique]
bonjour
vous allez bien
c'est une huile sur papier penser tout
de suite à un ciel dessus ce serait
peut-être des branchages ou des
feuillages ou des oiseaux comme une
estampe japonaise mais en fait pas du
tout je pense que c'est quelque chose de
complètement abstrait et
on se rendra encore plus compte avec la
grandissement
de la tapisserie
quand vous avez fait pour le dégradé
lui-même du bien tracé
les zones
en fait et quand on les voit travailler
c'est là où on se rend compte le temps
nécessaire du travail on voit que à
chaque fois elles prennent juste deux
trois fils et qu'elle change de broche
en permanence
[Musique]
la majorité des oeuvres c'est comme ça
oui quand on tisse une oeuvre il est
très rare qu'on sache à l'avance sa
destination
étant donné que toutes les œuvres qui
sont tissées ici
servent à meubler les résidences de
l'État donc on ne peut pas savoir
forcément quel goût va avoir un ministre
ou un autre
[Musique]
le fait de garder de promouvoir c'est
savoir faire c'est une forme de
résistance peut-être on peut dire à
l'invasion de la technologie c'est un
autre rapport au temps c'est un c'est
l'intelligence de la main ce sont des
valeurs précieuses qu'il importe de
préserver parce que ça fait partie de
l'image de prestige de la France et
parce que ce sont des choses qui sont
belles en soi et qui serait dommage
d'abandonner
[Musique]
la savonnerie porte ce nom un peu
étonnant pour une manufacture de tapis
tout simplement parce que
elle a été installée dans les lieux
d'une ancienne manufacture de savon
douce d'où ce nom installé à Chaillot et
cette manufacture s'est développée à
partir du règne de Louis XII et a connu
son apogée à partir du règne de Louis
XIV
[Musique]
ainsi de suite il y a rien qui a changé
depuis plus de 400 ans
on voit les emblèmes royaux dans le
compartiment central mais également un
nombre important de motifs qui visent à
montrer à quel point le royaume est
prospère sous le règne de Louis XIV on
peut voir par exemple des cornes
d'abondance qui viennent signifier qu'on
est à une époque où le royaume de France
connaît son apogée on a des scènes de
paysages complètement idéaux des scènes
de trophées pour montrer la puissance
également du royaume de France en somme
on est devant une commande qui s'inscrit
parfaitement dans le cadre de toutes ces
grandes commandes royales visant à
mettre en scène la gloire du souverain
[Musique]
lorsqu'il y avait des enfants qui
perdaient leur père ou donc du coup de
la mer ne pouvait plus subvenir aux
besoins ont demandé s'il pouvait entrer
comme apprenti soit au gobelins soit à
la savonnerie donc c'est un peu une
politique sociale de la part de la
couronne c'est pas systématique mais ça
entre dans cette politique sociale
[Musique]
on va faire venir des dentelières de
Venise notamment pour piquer leur
technique on va espionner enfin cette
histoire d'espionnage industrielle pour
pour tenter d'acquérir leur technique et
après on va développer des points
spécifiquement français qu'on va appeler
point de France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma base de travail je travaille
sur le carton je croise mes fuseaux
suivant les points codifiés sur le
carton et je pose mes épingles sur
chaque trou dans chaque trou répliquer
pour avoir la régularité des points
nécessaires là j'utilise un point de ce
qu'on appelle de maths pour réaliser le
fond d'amis qui est dessiné sur sur le
carton où on le retrouve là
on le retrouve dans les fleurs et dans
toute cette bordure épaisse qui sera à
la bordure extérieure du tapis c'est un
point de mat donc voilà je croise
mon point
et arriver au bout je vais mettre
l'épingle pour pouvoir tourner
[Musique]
j'en connais plusieurs centaines mais il
y en a encore beaucoup plus on les
connaît pas tous on en apprend au fur et
à mesure
[Musique]
nous voici dans ces fameuses ateliers
des Gobelins c'est ici que depuis Louis
XIV et Colbert les meilleurs artisans
fabriquent ces tapisseries qui
émerveillent le monde aujourd'hui une
centaine d'artisans y sont à l'oeuvre
avec le garde-meuble de la couronne
Louis XIV et Colbert ont mis en route un
outil de production qui fonctionne
encore aujourd'hui et qui a gardé tout
son prestige actuellement 9 tapisseries
sont en fabrication sur les métiers des
Gobelins
la Louis XIV Louis XV a de grands
projets pour le garde-meuble il décide
de lui dédier un hôtel particulier un
bâtiment somptueux qui se situe sur ce
qui va devenir la place de la Concorde
ce bâtiment existe toujours aujourd'hui
il est occupé par le ministère de la
Défense et donc fermé au public mais
très exceptionnellement nous avons eu
l'autorisation différentes et nos
caméras
[Musique]
c'était à la limite de Paris et c'est
dans c'était dans une zone considérée
comme très insalubre parce que il y
avait cette immense espace de la place
de la Concorde qui était pas pavé mais
boueux il n'y avait pas de pont encore
pour passer sur la rive gauche et à côté
comment c'est tout de suite le bois des
Champs-Élysées qui était horriblement
malfamé c'est comme le bois de Boulogne
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il y avait
pas mal de créatures nocturnes
[Musique]
tout le public pouvait visiter les
mardis les salles d'exposition c'était
gratuit c'était protégé et garder c'est
la première fois que vous aviez cette
ancêtre du musée dans l'acception que
l'on a maintenant
[Musique]
la première salle montrait les armures
et les armes des rois de France les
armures de gala donc les plus
somptueuses ensuite une longue galerie
présentait les meubles d'étoffes les
plus prestigieux et les plus riches donc
brocard meuble brodé de perles le
tapisserie et dans la dernière salle
vous aviez les vases en pierre dur de la
couronne donc en Jazz pour la pilasse du
lit en Agathe avec leur monture d'or et
d'argent la richesse des collections
éblouissaient les visiteurs et entre
autres un militaire qui écrit ses
mémoires du temps de Napoléon se
souvenait de l'impression que qu'avait
fait sur lui enfant et les armures des
rois de France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Paris le roi à Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prenez bien soin de mon pauvre
Versailles dit le roi à Monsieur de
gouvernet quand il quitte le château et
il ne le reverra plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec la chute de la monarchie le
garde-meuble n'avait plus de raison
d'être sa charge était de meubler les
résidences royales faute de monarchie
plus de résidence royale donc petit à
petit à partir de 1792 on a posé les
scellés sur toutes les résidences
royales on a fait des inventaires très
précis en faisant de l'eau un lot qu'il
réservait et un lot qui devait être
vendu les conventionnelles avaient tout
à fait conscience qu'ils avaient un
trésor qu'il pouvait monnayer
[Musique]
une date qui a marqué ça a été le retour
du bureau du roi en 1957 parce que le
bureau du roi a une valeur de symbole
comme étant la plus belle pièce
d'ébénisterie du 18e siècle
[Musique]
d'un seul mouvement de clé le mécanisme
permettait de déverrouiller le système
de permettre de relever le cylindre et
de permettre aux souverain de tirer les
petits tiroirs latéraux et ces
mécanismes sont complétés par d'autres
mécanismes internes aux meubles qui
consiste en fait à deux loquets qui une
fois que le cylindre est soulevé
permettent de transformer le plateau
soit en pupitre soit même ce pupitre
peut par un système de bascule s'ouvrir
et laisser apparaître une cache dans
lequel vous avez à nouveau trois petits
tiroirs
[Musique]
les principales modifications ont été
dans les médaillons latéraux et bien le
changement des doubles l qui était en
fait le chiffre de Louis XV et remplacé
par ces plaques de porcelaine de
Wedgwood
[Musique]
et de la galerie des Glaces où le
déjeuner de better servi comme il le fut
voici bientôt 20 ans au roi Georges VI
son père sa Majesté Isabelle pouvait
découvrir par les immenses baies
l'ordonnance magnifique des jardins de
Lenôtre où les eaux les pierres les
bronzes et les feuillages s'unissent
pour dessiner l'un des plus beaux cadres
du monde
[Musique]
alors le partenariat avec le Mobilier
national nous apporte une grande
quantité de meubles une centaine de
meubles de très très grande qualité
certains d'entre eux sont des bons
meubles alors quand à Versailles on dit
il s'agit d'un bon meuble ça veut dire
le bon meuble à la bonne place
c'est-à-dire le meuble qui était
véritablement là
[Musique]
on est au cœur du château et pour les
gens qui vivaient à Versailles pouvaient
vivre une vie entière et ne jamais
pénétrer dans ces pièces on s'est
efforcé de donner par le nombre d'objets
cette idée de densité que l'on trouve
dans les inventaires et on est au plus
haut niveau de qualité parce que je
pense que c'est l'une des pièces au
monde où l'on a de le plus grand nombre
de pièces de mobilier ou d'objets d'Arc
qui ont véritablement appartenu à
Marie-Antoinette
mais on ne peut pas évidemment
dépouiller l'Élysée comme on pourrait
dépouiller le secrétariat d'une
administration secondaire dans province
quand je suis rentré dans la salle de
transit du Mobilier national je suis
tombé sur ce paravent et évidemment je
n'attendais que lui je ne l'avais jamais
vu en réalité je le connaissais mais je
ne l'avais jamais vu et évidemment quand
il est apparu comme ça dans toute sa
splendeur dans toutes sens sa force je
me suis dit voilà il faut qu'il retourne
à Versailles il y a pas d'autre choix
[Musique]
voilà la lanterne qui va
merveilleusement ici elle est
parfaitement elle remplit vraiment le
volume de toute façon elle correspond au
point de vue des des dimensions ça
enrichit considérablement la pièce qu'on
voit que c'est une pièce absolument
extraordinaire par la qualité de la
ciselure dans l'originalité aussi des
motifs et elle coûtait un prix fou déjà
à l'époque un prix astronomique on peut
le dire quand on se rappelle toutes les
négociations qu'il y a eu pour l'obtenir
à peu près 4 ans oui ça a été un petit
peu une succession de péripéties
cette lanterne on la remet dans un
contexte où il y a une cohérence
historique voilà cette cohérence
historique elle n'existait pas à
Matignon le deuxième argument c'est de
dire que ce sera vu par le public et ça
c'est un argument auquel le Premier
ministre a été extrêmement sensible
voilà les arguments les plus les plus
forts
[Musique]
table était à l'hôpital de Fontainebleau
malheureusement elle a été volée et
pendant son vol elle a été endommagée
c'est-à-dire que le marbre a été laissé
sur place mais casser cassé en plusieurs
morceaux la table a été retrouvée chez
un brocanteur coupé en deux pour passer
un peu inaperçu il a fallu déjà
refusionner les deux parties qui étaient
coupés et malheureusement elle a perdu
le motif central c'était un bouquet de
fleurs
[Musique]
j'ai une surface qui n'est pas du tout
sensible à l'eau
donc ça veut dire qu'elle est soit cirée
soit vernis soit huileuse mais j'ai des
petites pépites de dorure et j'ai une
couleur qui apparaît un peu verte donc
là je vais m'attaquer à autre chose que
que de l'eau parce que j'arrive pas à
voir suffisamment profondément
je vais prendre des solvants on est dans
une sculpture très Louis XIV ici on a
quelque chose de très sculpté c'est
quelque chose de très très disquette
les années 770
1680 la grande époque versaillesse oui
tout à fait
les pépites d'or en dessous qui sont
très présentes sont des sortes de
paillettes en fait qui sont c'est plus
que des paillettes regardent plus que
des paillettes ah oui ah oui oui
en fait c'était entièrement doré
on est à la base je pense sur un meuble
de très grande qualité
on peut imaginer qu'elle était dorée
quand elle était à la cour et puis quand
elle passe à l'hôpital on juge que c'est
trop riche et on l'a peint à ce
moment-là dans un dans un ton un peu un
peu bleuté plus neutre plus plus
monastique ça c'est pas impossible c'est
on espère un jour la présentation soit
dans une galerie comme la galerie des
Gobelins en Mobilier national soit dans
un lieu plus prestigieux comme au Louvre
si l'objet en vaut la peine
[Musique]
1870 une mesure effectivement de
précaution et qui a été vraiment une
mesure miraculeuse à cet égard a
consisté à rapatrier au Louvre un
certain nombre de meubles qui étaient
déposé dans les différents palais et il
est bien sûr bien national
[Musique]
et puis ensuite il y a le gros très gros
versement de 1901 du meubier National
qu'il a est le fond constitutif du
département des objets d'art avec
effectivement un ensemble tout à fait
éblouissant de meubles de bronze
d'ameublement et de tapisseries
[Musique]
chaussures quoi on peut fixer son regard
c'est la qualité de l'Afrique candée par
ces motifs de masques de Lyon qui
viennent se placer au dessus des
chapiteaux très délicatement découpés
dans des figures d'attentes le pied
lui-même est en forme de carquois c'est
un thème récurrent de la deuxième moitié
du XVIIIe siècle il est traité ici avec
une particulière élégance
[Musique]
elle est difficilement lisible pu sous
une couronne fermée avec le numéro
d'inventaire c'est la marque au pochoir
noir sous les Philippe du palais des
Tuileries
ça veut dire que ce siège était dans un
appartement officiel des Tuileries sous
Louis Philippe vers 1840
[Musique]
dans les années 30 ils ont fait des
cartes postales des photos par exemple
celle-ci qui est très connue qui l'a vu
côté cheminée ce qu'on est en train de
reconstituer là celle-ci était beaucoup
moins connue c'est la vue côté alcôve et
celle là on a on a réussi à la retrouver
et elle nous permet d'avoir donc cette
vision 360 qui permet de compléter
idéalement le grand savon peut-être
qu'il était
bon ça fonctionne parfaitement retrouve
exactement ce que l'on a sur la photo à
la fois les deux les deux rangs
parallèles de siège pour la
représentation l'écran de cheminée qui
axe les deux rentes fauteuils de siège
on essaie de se mettre à la place de ces
occupants qui ne sont plus là et de
façon à ne pas trahir leur goût et leur
la façon qu'ils avaient de vivre c'est
ça qui est important c'est ça qui finit
par faire sens parce que à la fin
évidemment on se sent dans quelque chose
de chaleureux en quelque chose de
vivable
[Musique]
on a la chance pour nous mais la
malchance pour lui que le maréchal de
Saxe soit mort à Chambord en novembre
1750 et donc on a fait ce qu'on faisait
dans toutes les successions on a fait un
inventaire après décès et donc grâce à
cette inventaire pluie à d'autres
inventaires au moins un au 18e et un
révolutionnaire on a un sorte de
photographie de ce qui restait de
mobilier au château en 1750
[Musique]
c'est un meuble intéressant puisque
c'est un meuble qui provient du fond de
ministère de la guerre le ministère de
la guerre est un des ministères
régaliens de l'ancien régime qui était
installé avec à Versailles près du
château et quand les les ministères des
ménages à la Révolution dès 1789 la
plupart des ministères en Maine leur
meubles donc c'est certainement un
meuble de l'ancien fond du ministère de
la guerre à Versailles
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans la galerie des
Gobelins c'est la seule partie du
Mobilier national qui soit ouverte au
public vous pourrez y admirer
quelques-uns des plus précieux trésors
de la tapisserie française
nous venons de le voir les trésors que
conservent le Mobilier national
permettent de remubler quelques-uns de
nos plus beaux châteaux mais sa mission
la plus importante est aussi de veiller
à l'ameublement des lieux où travaillent
ce qui nous gouverne comme l'Élysée ou
les ministères c'est le rôle des
inspecteurs
[Musique]
si on a des frustrant sur la terre c'est
beau aujourd'hui
le salon changer de salon
elles sont là sont les amis plus
il y a de l'eau potable alors l'étape
bourré à la fin de l'inspection on
regarde si on a bien tout coché si on
n'a pas tout coché il s'agit de
retrouver l'objet donc on va refaire
toutes les pièces jusqu'à ce que l'objet
soit identifié si les pas identifié on
ferait un courrier pour leur demander de
continuer les recherches et si jamais
l'objet vraiment ne pas on ne parvient
pas à retrouver l'objet là on demandera
un dépôt de plainte c'est une mission
qui est quand même importante dans la
mesure où c'est quand même le patrimoine
de la France
[Musique]
donc les marques anciennes et le gmtc la
marque actuelle
[Musique]
le décor ne suffit pas à lui-même le
lieu a besoin de vibrer de vivre et puis
quand on explique à certains visiteurs
du Grand Chancelier que ce sont les
sièges de la Grande Duchesse de Toscane
sort de l'empereur
les gens avant de s'asseoir regardent
toujours le meuble un peu différemment
qu'une chaise ou qu'un fauteuil
ordinaire
une chose c'est qu'il faudrait qu'on
prévoit vous voyez de l'aiguille qui
montre les minutes ça aurait perdu un
élément et vous l'avez regardez bien sûr
bien sûr donc il faudrait qu'on prévoit
la restauration de la de l'aiguille bon
très bien on va le marquer
toutes les semaines
donc je le note alors l'aiguille
restauration de l'aiguille
[Musique]
ça c'est un siège qui fait partie d'un
ensemble qui se trouve dans le bureau du
président quand le président reçoit des
gens dans son bureau ils sont
certainement invités s'asseoir sur ce
salon
[Musique]
je vous montre
l'ancien tissu voilà c'était sur le
fauteuil juste avant voyez c'est surtout
la partie jaune qui s'est patiné
naturellement et on avait sur le nouveau
tissu le jaune est quand même plus
flagrant après bon bah c'est la lumière
qui atténue les couleurs donc c'est pour
ça qu'on change le tissu pour que ça
reste toujours impeccable pour une
maison comme l'Élysée il faut quand même
que le mobilier reste en excellent état
[Musique]
le tissu doit être posé exactement de la
même manière d'un siège à l'autre c'est
au millimètre près on n'oserait pas
s'asseoir dessus d'ailleurs c'est à dire
qu'on les fait mais il nous viendrait
pas l'idée nous asseoir dessus ils sont
faits pour pour le président
[Musique]
c'est comme un plâtre très fin qui
mélangeait avec des alcool de peau des
colles animales et on l'applique avec
des petites brosses et des pinceaux sur
le bois voilà ça permet ensuite de faire
une fois que c'est sec de faire des
lissages et de faire disparaître tous
les défauts du bois
[Musique]
voilà je prépare la colle de peau de
lapin qui va nous servir à poser la
poudre d'or donc alors on a un de ces
trois poudre d'or
voilà qui va nous servir à
donc à reconstituer les usures on va
procéder par pigmentation
le principe c'est une fois qu'on a une
fois avoir appliqué la poudre c'est de
brunir d'ailleurs de donner une
brillance alors voilà parce qu'une fois
que l'or est posé il reste relativement
mat voilà donc là on va vouloir recréer
une brillance donc c'est une sorte de
polissage
et donc on voit là les parties qui
commencent à briller
voilà alors que les fonds vont rester
mat
[Musique]
un titre indicatif il y a quand même
1600 mètres de tissu ça c'est parlant
parce que quand on dit aux gens 1600
mètres quand même il y a 180 mètres de
franges à qui là c'est rideau là où je
pense que c'est plutôt les autres là ils
pèse 17 kg chacun c'était un remuer à
l'atelier quand on les a fait c'était
quand même un peu costaud
la question est la suivante comment vous
portez vous je vais vous répondre tout
de suite
je ne vais pas mal
mais rassurez-vous un jour je ne
manquerai pas de mourir
[Musique]
là vous rentrez en fait dans la réserve
la plus précieuse toujours fermée à clé
et qui est en fait un peu le saint des
saints pour le textile
donc là on est dans la réserve des
soirées c'est une réserve qui possède
des trésors et des trésors inestimables
comme tout ce qui était lié à l'histoire
du Garde-Meuble depuis son origine
jusqu'à nos jours et surtout à
l'ameublement des châteaux donc on a par
exemple des éléments du 18e siècle dont
les plus anciennes commandes sont celles
de 1730 dont je vais vous montrer un
exemple
[Musique]
alors quand vous voyez déjà la lourdeur
et en fait
l'épaisseur du tissu
voilà si tu peux m'aider
en fait on se rend compte que on a un
état de conservation déjà extraordinaire
et en plus on se rend compte de la
qualité puisqu'on a différents types de
fil d'or
là vous avez des fils d'or le plus
simple qui existe c'est à dire qu'on a
une arme en soi et on va mettre un fil
de retour après vous avez un petit peu
plus épais on va prendre un fil plus
épais et on va tourner au plus large
avec un bout d'or plus grand et vous
avez ce qu'on appellerait presque de la
cantine qui est en fait carrément un
élément de métal enroulé qui fait un
espèce de ressort sur un fil d'or on a
pas d'oxydation donc la qualité de l'or
était assez extraordinaire
[Musique]
les échantillons directement arrivés de
Lyon et aussi de venir magnifique on a
dit une comme ça une comme ça trois
comme celle-là celle-là le tissu
[Musique]
on va faire livrer en 1785 un ensemble
pour Marie-Antoinette avec des grands
éléments et surtout des très gros
papillons ça va être mis un été ça va
lui déplaire totalement donc en urgence
on va redemander autre chose
[Musique]
et en fait c'est un ensemble qui est
encore célèbre aujourd'hui c'est la
seule pièce qui reste au Mobilier
national lié à cet ensemble et qui a la
mémoire de ce travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on reconnaît au bruit
voilà ce petit chef de
c'est incroyable
c'est pour le moment un des plus beaux
qu'on est fait depuis 20 25
au moins 25 ans
nous voir pour pour différents modèles
puisqu'on a quand même un fond de
collection important
mais on a rarement la chance de voir un
tissage à bras derrière souvent c'est
pour retisser d'un point de vue
mécanique et là de se dire que on voit
tisser un tissu 18e à la manière du 18e
c'est un événement d'avoir cette vérité
historique qui est jusque dans la
technique
mais vous êtes au courant de couleur là
il y a combien de couleurs
32 couleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour m'y retrouver parce que j'ai
certaines couleurs qui se ressemblent
énormément
après on a des aides on a une petite
cloche qui est ici
qui vient me dire attention il y a une
couleur qui arrive il y a une couleur
qui part en fonction de où est-ce qu'on
est dans le tissu et j'ai des petits
mouchères en fait qui sont ici qui vont
m'indiquer en fait la couleur à passer à
ce moment là
[Musique]
on le refait à l'identique comme si
était neuf et qu'on allait livrer la
première fois à la reine il faut le
reconstituer le mieux possible donc le
dessin pas très compliqué on y arrive la
grosse difficulté comme toujours se
retrouver les couleurs parce que les
couleurs aujourd'hui c'est des couleurs
qui sont complètement à fadir qui ont
disparu et qui ont pu virer etc donc il
faut recomposer quelque chose qui aurait
pu être
[Musique]
on peut pas non plus sauver tous les
savoir-faire c'est absolument impossible
donc on fait le maximum pour garder nos
savoir-faire mais à un moment où il faut
quand même savoir déléguer
[Musique]
ici on vous a sorti la pendule la
pendule sympathique qui a été acheté par
Louis-Philippe en fait il y a une montre
que je vais aller vous chercher elle est
très très précieuse
[Musique]
à midi et à minuit une tige va sortir de
la pendule va rentrer dans la montre et
va remettre à l'heure automatiquement la
montre c'est le principe de la pendule
sympathique c'est l'osmose en fait qui a
entre la montre et la pendule qui donne
le nom probablement à pendule
sympathique au nom pendule sympathique
[Musique]
James et manus que vous pouvez me sortir
la pendule qui représente le wi-fi libre
s'il vous plaît merci
[Musique]
c'est bon
le sujet de la pendule est indiqué ici
il est marqué le roi Louis-Philippe
saigne de sa propre main et rappelle à
la vie le courrier de cabinet Werner
tombé de cheval sous les roues de sa
voiture le 27 octobre 1833
Louis-Philippe en immortalisant cette
scène a voulu montrer qu'en fait c'était
il était près de son peuple et qu'il
était prêt à faire tout ce qu'il fallait
pour sauver son courrier de cabinet les
pendules bien évidemment ont un rôle
utilitaire un rôle décoratif mais
souvent elle délivre des messages
[Musique]
cette chaumière est extraordinaire il
n'y a pas un espace qui ne soit pas
décoré
en coquillages divers et variés on sait
qu'ils viennent de la plage de Dieppe et
également il y a des coquillages qui
viennent des Antilles
[Musique]
là ce sont des jonds d'eau des agents
avec des petites branches de corail et
l'assise de la chaise repose sur une
valve de coquillages
et ensuite nous remontons avec un motif
tout aussi relié au coquillages mais qui
est ici peint et à l'arrière vous avez
un motif d'écailles qui est un également
[Musique]
et vous voyez également la forme de la
valve du coquillage
[Musique]
la princesse de Lamballe à la Révolution
l'avait émigré à l'étranger et par
fidélité à la reine elle est revenue
elle a été emprisonnée
elle a fait l'objet d'un procès
extrêmement rapide à la suite duquel
s'est évanoui et là les insurgés ou les
révolutionnaires se sont vraiment ruées
sur sa personne et elle a eu un destin
extrêmement Funès certains textes disent
qu'elle a été déshabillée puis par la
suite décapité sa tête a parue sur une
pique
[Musique]
cette table on l'appelle le bureau de
Louis XV pour son château de Choisy bon
l'appel aussi table de Robespierre il y
aurait des traces de son sang puisque
c'est sur cette table même qu'il va
agoniser pendant pratiquement une
journée avant d'être exécuté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le plan du symboles c'est très fort
puisque Robespierre qui incarne la
terreur l'incorruptibles va agoniser
pendant plusieurs heures sur célestes de
l'Ancien Régime sur cette table de Louis
XV et c'est vrai que donc c'est un beau
symbole de la fin de l'Ancien Régime
mais aussi de la chute du nouveau régime
celui de celui de la terreur
[Musique]
une chambre en 10 chambres et surtout le
cabinet de travail qui va être le lieu
central pendant les campagnes là où
Napoléon va vraiment faire ses
stratégies et tant de ces cartes
discuter avec ces généraux les réunir il
va toujours s'asseoir sur le fauteuil il
va accueillir ses généraux avec des
tabourets
[Musique]
Napoléon va emmener sur le champ de
bataille tout ce qui peut aussi donner
l'image de son empire et de sa place
d'empereur c'est important autant pour
son armée mais aussi pour ses ennemis il
va choisir les meilleurs artisans pour
montrer la force de la France il va
choisir des tissus de toile de Jouy qui
sont des tissus prestigieux il va avoir
les meilleurs soirées les meilleurs
laines
[Musique]
c'est un défilé auquel Vienne assister
la majorité la grande grande écrasante
majorité de Parisiens on va retrouver le
bourgeois le noble les gens d'église et
le prolétariat des faubourgs c'est
l'empereur qui revient et c'est l'église
qui va accueillir les restes donc il y a
du religieux du politique du culturel de
la scénographie du théâtre
[Musique]
ce tissu en plus reprend tous les motifs
typiquement napoléonien le foudre
Jupiter l'aigle et bien sûr le N il y en
a aussi avec des éléments d'abeilles
on a commandé un tissu très particulier
en fait puisqu'il est entièrement fait
en soi et surtout fibre de verre en fait
tous les éléments que vous voyez là qui
sont totalement dorés ce ne sont pas du
tout du fil d'or mais un fil de verre
dans lequel on a ajouté un oxyde qui
donne cette couleur dorée on voit
ressortir des petits éléments de verre
ce côté fil de verre je me fascine et à
chaque fois que je le sors mais me plaît
il est aussi une belle image de ce que
peut conserver le Mobilier national
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
comme vous le voyez les réserves du
Mobilier national sont comme un grand
livre d'histoire en trois dimensions ici
derrière chaque objet se cache une
partie de notre histoire mais le rôle du
Mobilier national est aussi de fabriquer
des trésors pour les générations futures
en 1963 le ministre de la Culture André
Malraux décide de créer un atelier de
recherche et création l'arc c'est de cet
atelier que va naître en France qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le design un style
qui va faire son entrée par la grande
porte le palais de l'Élysée
[Musique]
la particularité tout au moins dans le
salon et que les sièges sont intégrés à
l'architecture dans sable et que le mur
lui-même sert de dossier au siège
[Musique]
du miel voici Monsieur le Président
votre salle à manger privée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on en est plus là le design
bien connu à pignons sur rue mais
atelier reste un espace de liberté pour
les créateurs dans la mesure où il leur
offre une possibilité d'expérimenter et
des techniques nouvelles il pourrait
difficilement mettre à profit dans le
domaine de l'entreprise privée
[Musique]
très bien
à chaque fois qu'on change de place à
chaque fois que la lumière change la
table change c'est extraordinaire
c'est la première fois que je vois ça
c'est un beau projet
[Musique]
ça a été un travail énorme
c'est la fin d'une belle histoire
[Musique]
et je voulais que dans cette date de 6
juin
de cours
là il y a citron fait donc c'est trop
fait par cette branche ça fait 42
drapeaux comme ça à clouté à chaque fois
très très fier de travailler pour la
République
c'est ici que se termine notre émission
dans ce bâtiment où nous l'avons vu des
hommes et des femmes consacrent leur vie
à préserver des trésors qui nous
appartiennent afin que nous puissions
tous en profiter c'est aussi grâce à eux
que le savoir-faire accumulé par des
générations d'artisans continuent à se
transmettre et c'est probablement ce
savoir-faire qui est le bien le plus
précieux du Mobilier national pour ma
part je vous retrouve très bientôt pour
une nouvelle émission et nous partirons
ensemble à la découverte de nouveaux
trésors
[Musique]